the IMF is uniquely trained and highly  motivated specialists without equal  immune to any countermeasures but it is  an agency of chaos  mr. chairman the time has come to  dissolve the IMF shutting down the IMF  is a mistake you may regret you and the  team will answer for every wanton act of  mayhem you are responsible for they're  coming after us with everything they've  got your mission should you choose to  accept it  Ethan you really should you or any  member of your team be caught or kill  Secretary will disavow any knowledge of  your actions this may very well be our  last mission  you can't explain yourself brand-new  account this message will self-destruct  in five seconds  now come on right now